Donald Trump showed up at a Boy Scout
rally called the National Scout Jamboree
and went so crazy that the Boy Scouts of
America are now distancing themselves
from the bizarre political nature of
Trump's speech the other day if you know
anything about the Boy Scouts of America
the last president you'd think they'd
distance themselves from would be Donald
Trump but that's exactly what's going on
Trump showed up to talk to the Boy
Scouts talked about fake news went on a
tirade against Obamacare went on a
tirade against Barack Obama talked about
the fake media talked about the cesspool
or sewer of politicians in Washington DC
these are kids mostly these are children
that Donald Trump is talking to then he
went on to brag about his electoral
college victory and the popular vote he
said and you know we have a tremendous
disadvantage in the electoral vote the
popular vote is much easier at another
point he noted quote and by the way
under the Trump administration you'll be
saying Merry Christmas again when you go
shopping believe me
Merry Christmas here is a little bit of
Donald Trump at this event you want to
achieve your dreams I said who the hell
wants to speak about politics when I'm
in front of the Boy Scout right as the
Scout law says
a scout is trustworthy loyal we could
use some more loyalty I will tell you
that did President Obama ever come to a
Jamboree ooh
do you remember that incredible night
with the maps and the Republicans are
red and the Democrats are blue and that
map was so red it was unbelievable truly
seems like he was having a medical
incident of some kind it was just out
there behavior and to put a really fine
point on it I thought it would be funny
to compare what Dwight D Eisenhower said
at the 3rd National Boy Scout Jamboree
back in 1953 and then compare it to what
Donald Trump said so here's here's Ike
okay where he said quote to the voice
kept I am confident that in meeting and
talking with your fellow Scouts you will
gain a renewed awareness of the need for
cooperating working together in our
country and in the world bonds of common
purpose and common ideals can unite
people even when they come from the most
distant and diverse places this is an
important lesson and even if you learn
no other you will leave Irvine Ranch
with a new wisdom quite poetic quite
inspirational I like Ike quite a nice
little speech from Ike and now here is
some of what Donald Trump said to the
Boy Scouts in 2017 hey what am I going
to do he sounds like a nice person hee
hee I do I do love you by the way just a
question did President Obama ever come
to a Jamboree and we'll be back we'll be
back the answer is no but we'll be back
in life in order to be successful and
you people are well on the road to
success you have to find out what makes
you excited what makes you want to get
up each morning and go to work you have
to find it if you love what you do and
dedicate yourself to your work then you
will gain momentum and look you have to
you need the word momentum you will gain
that momentum and each success will
create another success the word momentum
I'll tell you a story that's very
interesting for me when I was young
there was a man named William Levitt you
have some here you have some in
different states anybody hear of
Levittown and he was a very successful
man became unbelievable he was a home
builder became a nun but the
unbelievable success and got more and
more successful and he'd build homes and
at night he'd go to these major sites
with teams of people and he'd scour the
sites for
nails and sawdust and small pieces of
wood and they clean the site so when the
workers came in the next morning the
sites would be spotless and clean and he
did it properly and he did this for 20
years and then he was offered a lot of
money for his company and he sold this
company for a tremendous amount of money
at the time especially this is a long
time ago sold his company for a
tremendous amount of money and he went
out and bought a big yacht and he had a
very interesting life I won't go any
more than that because your Boy Scouts
so I'm not going to tell you what he did
a different type of poetry
I guess gotta say from Trump to the Boy
Scouts I mean there are times where you
have to act as if you're the president
of everyone and out of the Boy Scouts
it's so easy to do you can just talk
about service and patriotism your
fraternity and all enough yeah it's a
gimme you can't just always act as if
you're the leader of a political party
and you know maybe go off of a
teleprompter every now and then well
endless parents and there was one they
are interestingly enough but he seemed
to be going off teleprompter if you know
what I mean endless parents of Boy
Scouts spoke out saying it was
outrageous Boy Scouts immediately
distancing themselves from this aboard
of speech they put out a statement
saying the Boy Scouts of America is
wholly nonpartisan
and does not promote any one position
product/service political candidate or
philosophy which is not true I mean it's
officially true but the Boy Scouts is
known by and large as an organization
that is much more sensitive to
conservative ideas and they've had
issues with homophobia and so on and so
forth so what they're saying is true but
it's not even really true the letter of
it may be true the spirit isn't and they
still put this out interesting little
tidbit for you Pat President Obama
George W Bush and Bill Clinton all were
Boy Scouts Donald Trump was not and
Obama did go to the Gymboree he did so
in 2010 I'm surprised Donald Trump did
in fact check himself before he said
that in front of a thousand people yeah
they're really hard to believe